mesdames messieurs bon dimanche Justin
Trudeau espérer à calmer la crise qui le
suit depuis plus de deux semaines or les
solutions qu'il a proposé n'ont fait que
galvaniser l'opposition l'enquête du
comité de parlementaire sur la sécurité
nationale et l'idée de confier à un
rapporteur spécial le mandat de
déterminer s'il faut aller plus loin n'a
rien fait pour calmer l'opposition qui
réclame plus que jamais la tenue d'une
enquête publique pour faire la lumière
sur l'ingérence de la Chine lors des
dernières élections les communes sont
devenues le théâtre de débat acrimonieux
d'attaques incisives le gouvernement
peut-il encore calmer la donne sans
céder aux demandes de ses adversaires
gouvernement autoritaire de Pékin
essayer de supporter juste un troudeau
et de l'aider Justin Trudeau et au
courant de cette ingérence depuis une
décennie il a
cachés veulent savoir exactement ce qui
s'est passé c'est pour ça je suis une
enquête indépendante et rigoureuse par
un rapporteur spécial par NSA par ncra
vont être la façon de pouvoir assurer
les Canadiens
[Musique]
du Québec pour le Parti conservateur
merci d'être avec nous on a beaucoup
parlé des gens chinois cette semaine le
Premier ministre a mis sur la table une
ébauche de solution la semaine dernière
le rapporteur spécial que vous avez
dénoncé d'entrée de jeu pourquoi c'est
pas une bonne idée
premièrement aussi actuellement on a
tellement d'informations qui ont été
couler aux médium on a premièrement ce
point de jeu partisan on le voit très
bien que l'information a coulée de
l'extérieur on est au courant que
l'ingérence il y a eu des problèmes avec
nos élections Canada 2021 donc d'arriver
commencer à vouloir reporter encore dans
le temps des solutions qui sont
immédiates c'est ceux qui fonctionnent
pas donc de nommer un rapporteur qui va
réfléchir à ceux qui vont proposer des
solutions on trouve que nous les députés
de position conservateur le bloc la NPD
on est 150 députés on est des bons
rapporteurs on peut dire on veut ce
qu'on veut nous c'est l'enquête publique
indépendante publique qui fonctionne
dans votre tête il y a différentes
personnes il y en a qui vont dire oui
c'est bon non c'est pas bon mais il
reste actuellement dans les moyens qu'on
peut demander parce que l'information
est connue les services secrets
connaissent l'information le Premier
ministre connaît l'information mais il
veut pas le divulguer donc pour nous
d'avoir un commissaire indépendant
choisi par les parties positions
collaboration avec le gouvernement c'est
la façon dont la plus transparente qu'on
peut trouver pour faire la lumière sur
tout ça on gère là on parle
d'information secrète très secret
comment on fait dans un contexte dans
lequel public des documents qu'on n'est
pas capable de dévoiler parce que ça
peut mettre ça peut mettre en péril la
sécurité du pays nos all avec les five
vases comment comment ça se fait une
enquête publique dans la mise en place
la commission d'enquête publique le
commissaire qui se renommé le ou la
commissaire aura des barèmes le les
parties de potions en ayant confiance
premièrement comme ça dans la dans
l'indépendance totale on pourra faire
confiance à cette personne-là qui pourra
dire pour certaines parties de l'enquête
je dois le faire à 8 lots mais je vais
avoir l'information donc on saura que la
personne en place comme ça on va
l'information il pourra arriver à la fin
et dire oui ou non s'il y a eu
l'ingérance mais sans donner les détails
sans publier les détails de façon
publique évidemment la semaine dernière
votre chef pratiquement dit que Monsieur
Trudeau était très très la nation est-ce
que ça ça vient pas un peu miner
l'institution démocratique dans laquelle
on se base qui mène le sens actuellement
c'est le fait que Monsieur Trudeau cache
la vérité il veut pas que les Canadiens
connaissent la vérité pourquoi lorsqu'on
cache la vérité lorsque par exemple
actuellement au comité de la procédure
de la Chambre des communes ça fait des
heures et des heures et des heures que
les parties de positions travaillent à
demander par que la quatrième la chef
des cabinets de Monsieur Trudeau vient
de témoigner les libéraux font tout pour
bloquer les processus la procédure du
comité parce que Madame tellefeuille
doit savoir des choses et de la elle
veut surtout pas venir témoigner donc ça
c'est un problème pour la démocratie
c'est un problème pour notre système
électoral pourquoi pourquoi il faut que
ça soit une interface pourquoi ça
pourrait pas pourquoi ça pourrait être
parce que l'information
[Musique]
Trudeau et là depuis 2015 elle a accepte
tous les rapports et on a su qu'elle
avait l'information elle aurait eu
l'information sur les rapports qui ont
été divulgués donc c'est pour ça on peut
avoir sa version des faits vous votre
sentiment quel est-il est-ce que est-ce
que qui a tiré avantage est-ce que
quelqu'un attirait avantage de ce qui
aurait pu se passer c'est super c'est
clair on l'a vu surtout l'élection de
2021 je suis un très bien kenitsu mon
collègue kinichu qui était député qui
habitait là en 2019 dans le coin de
Vancouver a perdu clairement à cause
d'influence monsieur il a dit ça a
contribué mais c'est pas le seul
toujours de plusieurs facteurs mais il
reste que l'opération concerté qui a été
fait par le régime communiste de Pékin
pour influencer la communauté snow
canadienne a voté contre les
conservateurs et spécifiquement dans le
contenu de Monsieur chou dans le comté
d'aller Swan d'un côté de Bob saveur en
Ontario c'est ces rapports-là justement
vont confirmer ou confirme c'est data et
c'est là que Monsieur Trudeau veut pas
que ça sache de façon officielle parce
que ça démontrerait que trois députés en
place qui ont été battus à cause
d'influence de Pékin plus les autres
candidats qui ont pas pu gagner pour les
mêmes raisons c'est grave là je reste la
Chine les agences d'autres pays les
spécialistes en sécurité nationale
disent pas un problème qui est unique au
Canada ça se passe ailleurs mais il faut
se protéger comme la liste par exemple
on va avoir la liste des agents
étrangers qui travaillent au Canada
comme l'Australie a fait en 2018 on doit
importer ça au Canada et c'est le seul
vendredi matin monsieur medicino a dit
on va lancer un processus pour moi ça
prend du temps et puis on parle de
vouloir aller vite donc il l'annonce en
disant on va le faire mais son
propriétés de le faire renforcer sur le
moment donné je pense que ce que les
citoyens demandent leur puis on fait pas
de partisanneries de notre côté on veut
vraiment protéger on parle de protéger
le Canada au militairement avec des
avions des bateaux mais quand on arrive
au niveau des élections où il y a des
gens sur le territoire canadien qui
viennent de la Chine pour influencer les
campus les élections à un moment donné
on fait quoi est-ce que c'est une menace
à notre sécurité nationale oui est-ce
que maintenant surtout aux élections aux
démocratiques absolument mais vous
l’impression que vous êtes capable de
faire bouger le gouvernement est-ce
qu'on a pas l'impression ça donne pas on
n'a pas le sentiment qu'ils ont envie de
te diriger vers l'enquête publique
présentement puis on n'a pas le
sentiment non plus que il y a beaucoup
de pression de la part des Canadiens
quand on regarde les sondages
énormément de pression sur le
gouvernement ça c'est un côté qui est
toujours comme je viens de parler dans
le fond la si on parle d'une incursion
d'un bombardier stratégique par exemple
chinois qui viendrait dans l'espace
aériens où on a vu les ballons
dernièrement bon là les gens sont plus
conscient que c'est quoi c'est de
l'espionnage chez nous mais lorsqu'on a
des gens infiltrés sur le territoire qui
font des opérations on le voit pas donc
c'est moins concret pour la population
et c'est pour ça qu'on doit en parler
qu'on doit faire comprendre que ça
existe il y a des rapports qu'ils
confirment et de l'homme importance du
gouvernement le premier c'est lui le
responsable de la sécurité démocratique
du Canada c'est à lui de dire si oui ou
non il y a eu de la gérance puis quels
sont les mesures qu'on va prendre pour
la corriger un mot en terminant sur vos
collègues qui ont rencontré cette député
allemande qu'on traversait qui qui
défend des opinions très à droite donc
partie est considéré et sous
surveillance présentement en Allemagne
justement pour les idées qui sont
avancées vos collègues ont été critiqués
là-dessus mais on les a pas entendu
énormément on n'a pas entendu monsieur
poignet non plus sur la place publique
dénoncé ouvertement il y a un petit
communiqué une déclaration mais on a
l'impression qu'il tente de ménager un
peu la chèvre
était clair elle dit que cette dame là
n'aurait pas dû être devenir au Canada
premièrement qu'il dénonçait fortement
ses propos sa façon d'être ce qu'elle
dit mes collègues aussi se sont excusés
publiquement donc je crois que c'est une
erreur de parcours pour mes collègues il
y aurait dû faire de meilleures
recherches avant merci